hello everyone and welcome to rational
science hey guys as you can see we're
we're back
i'm back uh he was uh anz was on a
secret mission
and we can't tell you anything about it
because it's a secret mission but uh all
we can say is maybe a little bit we can
say that
he went on a mission to um
rescue
a damsel in distress
would that be
pretty accurate and i gather you were
quite successful at it as well
okay
okay so uh
we'll see right
yeah
okay anyways uh we're gonna start out
with our science critic he made a
45-minute video criticizing
the scientific method
can you believe that the scientific
messages
scientific now of course
uh but yeah anybody's entitled to
criticize it right the question is
whether uh his criticisms have any
validity
so let me uh set this up so that you can
hear
in his own words what he said okay
and
give me a second here and we're ready um
almost on our way here we go
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal are
is the universe irrational
is it possible to observe a wave
function
and
does quantum mechanics propose the
collision of wave functions
those are all things that have been
observed though so are you saying that
the universe is irrational although to
be fair one of the things that i haven't
heard is colliding wave functions i have
heard of collapsing wave functions and
interfering wave functions but never of
colliding wave
functions okay
so uh two issues specifically one is
whether the universe is irrational
and the other one essentially you know
uh whether a wave function first can be
observed and then whether they can
collide
and so let's go with the first one
here's a rundown okay
and it goes like this
it's not that the universe is irrational
it's that the explanations people have
for how the universe works
that are irrational and there i'm giving
you some examples
uh the warpage of space-time or the
geometry of space-time is gravity
you know that's an irrational statement
you're saying that
time
has geometry
it's like saying that what's the
geometry of love what's the geometry of
intelligence what's the geometry of
consciousness the shape of time is that
what they're asking for well essentially
that's what it is because they're the
physical interpretation that they're
going to give is this bending of the
canvas the canvas represents space and
time and so essentially they're saying
that they're warping time and that's
gravity
and
it's okay if you want to do math and say
look time
goes slower or faster that's that's one
issue but when you give a physical
interpretation you cannot say that time
is warped which is essentially what they
have and then the others uh zero d black
hole you know uh a lot of people
are not aware that uh chandrasekhar
got a nobel prize for proving
that a black hole
is zero dimensional it collapses to zero
size
and people don't like to hear that they
say what do you mean zero size yeah
that's exactly what chandrasekhar got
his nobel prize for okay and so you have
an object that is zero size
no volume
lots of mass
which is a concept
in this
no volume no no size
uh region
and it makes stars go around and pulls
matter in
yeah sure
and then uh the other particles have two
places at once big bang creationism and
uh you know just an example there faster
than light tachyons arriving from the
future you know what is all this
and so um
it's not that the universe is irrational
it's that these people are giving
irrational explanations for how the
universe works the irrational uh the
irrationality consists primarily in the
movement of concepts okay that's that's
essentially the the
the the where the problem is i'm just
using magic at all i mean it's not even
messing black match yeah i mean even
even magic can't make one thing be in
two places at once like no one
understands it you can't even make a
program that makes sense of that like no
no i guess not right because uh if if
you give it a like you assign if you
assign a name to one object in your
program
i guess as soon as you have two
locations two objects like that's
basically the definition of
two two things is because it has two
locations
yeah so this is these are the things
that you got to keep in mind that they
have irrational explanation the universe
i'm sure works rationally i hope it does
to a certain point i mean but it gets
weird at the
at the infinitesimal level when you're
at the at the fundamental level it gets
a little weird but i guess at some point
it kind of has to yeah but not that
weird
the way i look at it is mother nature
father universe god devil the devil
whoever you pray to you know
they don't
know anything about concepts
okay we invented all concepts so they
work with objects you know all they do
is move objects from one place to
another every day primarily atoms you
know they work at the atomic level so
there's constant motion in the universe
of what of atoms that's it that's all
they understand
all these concepts
field energy mass we've invented all
that they you know mother nature and
father universe they know nothing about
all that they never would like i like to
say mother nature never into school she
knows nothing about math or arithmetic
okay that's us that give you know these
relations anyways um
second issue was uh whether you can have
uh a wave whether you can observe first
of all a wave function and then whether
wave functions can
collide can they actually collide i put
that in there and this was what was he
with what this fellow was criticizing
but he conceded
at least that they uh interfere and that
they um collapse
and what he didn't understand is that
there's no difference between
uh
interfere
uh collide and uh collapse because
you're treating the wave function as a
physical object in all three cases
that's the issue okay so let's look at
can you first issue is you know can you
can you even observe a wave function and
a wave function is what the second word
says it's a function and what's a a
function it's an equation it's a number
it's an amount it's a quantity
uh
so you can't say that a function
uh that you're going to observe a
function like floating out there in
space that's the issue and if you can't
observe it first of all
then how can you imagine that it
collapses okay
or interferes with another wave function
i mean what are we talking about is this
physics is this we have two wave
functions that hit each other that cross
each other what is this and so you know
here the uh first issue is how do you
observe uh numbers you know floating
around
moving right you can't do that um
how do numbers collapse what do you mean
by a number collapsing and what they uh
what they're saying in in quantum
mechanics is the following so let's
understand this
well so that we truly understand it okay
uh they say that the uh wave function
collapses to a point
why because when they take the
measurement
they take a measurement at a given spot
at a given point and they say what
happened was that this wave function
which is spread out throughout the
universe all the way to the edge of
space-time suddenly collapses
you know
concentrates all of a sudden
to a dot
and that dot is what they're going to
call a
particle
so let's look at what a particle is this
is from the
wikipedia an idealization of particles
heavily used in
i think they said mathematics but maybe
i i was too liberal with my wording
there okay but it's defining feature is
that what it lacks spatial extension
being dimensionless it does not take up
space
we're talking about nothing okay why
because we're talking about a concept
they're talking about a number a
quantity that's what a particle is
says a particle is an appropriate
representation of any object whenever
its size shape and structure
physics you know
are irrelevant in a given context
so they're talking about first a wave
function what is a wave function a bunch
of vectors what is a vector
it's got magnitude and direction and you
have a bunch of these arrows which
represent magnitude and direction and
they're moving sideways perpendicular to
those directions right
they're moving sideways and suddenly all
these vectors numbers right they
collapse
to
what they call a particle which is what
no spatial
volume no dimension dimensions they take
up no space basically they just tell you
about a location with
this stores properties exactly that they
measured
and so uh how do numbers physically
interfere because forget about my
colliding i put the colliding in there
forget about that if you want no problem
that's that's my
take but how do they interfere and how
do they collapse what are we talking
about are we saying that this
equation collapses to a dot
that or a point a ball of some kind what
is that
collapsed yeah so colliding interfere
and collapse in all three cases
whichever one you you want to pick there
is a physical interpretation of what
they measure
and this is where the problem comes in
are we doing math are we doing physics
if you want to do math no problem
measure all you want give me the
quantity no problem but when you say
that the number collapses to a little
ball
now we have a little bit of problem
that's where the problem is okay that
we have a number collapsing to a ball
okay and and that's scary well sometimes
like what you said earlier about the
warp space could you say something like
you can calculate useful things for with
mathematics as if it were war of space
so use the calculations for a warped
canvas but once you translate that into
real life as a physical mechanism it
gets weird where we would be crushing
the bottom of the earth on the
surface of space time so as an equation
but as a physical interpretation it
makes absolutely no sense right and
that's where the problem is the problem
is that uh the physical interpretations
and when people don't understand that
they say okay these people know all that
math they probably know what they're
talking about i don't understand that
that well you know now the question is
they don't have a physical
interpretation that you can take to the
bank that's what bothers the point
really because a lot of them reject that
as philosophy and they say well that's
for us that's opinion that's what they
what the particle looks like who cares
right it's like we don't care about that
we don't give a uh you know a real
physical interpretation we don't
understand how all that works we don't
care about that because we're doing math
and we call that physics
now no physics is what mother nature
does you need to explain gravity you
need to explain magnetism electricity
how the atom works that's physics but if
you just measure and give me an amount
and say this is how fast something is
this is how much it weighs or how much
mass it has now you're talking about
numbers yeah that's just describing yeah
and so you cannot translate that uh or
automatically convert it into physics
and say it's a ball that's you know
weighs space time downwards or whatever
that's where the problem is the the
transition from math to physics again
mathematical physics is a contradiction
in terms it's an oxymoron okay because
math is math physics is physics never
the twain shall meet
okay so here's a wave function just so
you see what it looks like okay what
they're talking about when they say a
wave function collapsed or it interfaced
or it
interfered or collided or whatever with
another wave function here it is that's
what it looks like that worm that you
see there okay
this is uh
follows it says
that
all these particles you know they form
this wave function and what are those
particles were their values so each one
of those balls that you see there that
form that
worm
well all those balls are also quantities
they're just talking about quantities
quantities and more quantities and
that's what the two axis there are
really
indicating you know this is just a
two axis and numbers on a cartesian
coordinate system that's all we're
looking at okay
so let's look at uh
let's look at what
really a wave function collapses okay
here it is okay and it's scary stuff so
if you're
this is not authorized for people under
18 so if you're under 18 please leave
right now okay this is dangerous stuff
here it is okay
here you have the uh
wave moving before measurement and then
it collapses
to a dot
that's a wave function collapse you
never saw it well now you've seen it in
this channel okay and so the question is
here you have a bunch of vectors they're
moving uh
transversely with respect to the
direction of each one of those vectors
that represent magnitude and direction
so they have numbers that are moving
that's what you're staring at they're
represented by these arrows and suddenly
that whole
bunch of numbers
collapses to a ball
which your nose is being watched
i never understood how physicists could
just accept that as an axiom like
the electrons know they're being watched
that matter reacts differently if their
eyes on it like that they just accepted
that like oh yeah that happens yeah in
one world the physical interpretation is
what is scary because in what was i
think 1926 when this was determined by
werner heisenberg and some of his pals
there schroedinger and so on what they
did they uh they
figured out things that they could not
see
so they had the quantities they had the
measurements
but they could not see
what they were measuring in other words
the the reaction was uh invisible or too
swift
so what they did was put particles in
there
but initially they started with
classical particles because that's what
they thought they were and classical
particles are balls
this is a classical particle here that's
what it looks like okay
uh it's a ball
and then they said well it's not really
a ball because
it's actually another quantity
that is at this location and so yeah
when you have that situation or you're
dealing with quantities but then the
physical interpretation gets lost in
translation and that's what happens and
you're saying that a number converts
into a particle because they have to
give you a physical interpretation
because that's what the reporter is
asking for he says well i don't care
about your numbers i mean what is it
what's the bottom line what does this
all mean and the guy says well you know
the wave function collapsed and so whoa
what is that well the number turned into
another number but it's it's it's a
pointed numbers like uh in that region
okay in fact someone someone said it
great for for light um he said
light travels
as a wave but departs and arrives as a
particle
that's the that's the definition or i
guess the the way of
representing light
and what are they saying well they're
just saying nonsense they're saying that
the parts as a particle arrives as a
particle in between it's a wave so you
you're not you don't really have balls
traveling through the air
that's not the notion that they have
they represent it that way but
you saw it just a minute ago how the
worm was made of all those little balls
so they still represented that way
because how are they going to represent
a wave if not with little tiny balls
that represent you know that whole wavy
thingy right but then they say it's it
departs as a ball it arrives as a ball
because that's what you can measure at a
point at a location in between it
travels or extends
as a wave
i mean uh you know like take for
instance
a wave of light a photon if you want to
see it that way a
wave packet however you want to see that
does it travel
or does it extend
[Music]
from the andromeda galaxy 2.2 million
light years away traveling at the speed
of light you would that's what the
distance is from there to the milky way
so does it extend from there to here
or does it travel
and if it ext if it travels where does
the wave begin where does the wave end i
mean is it a little row boat that's uh
you know traveling through space without
hitting anything is that how it is or is
it or does it extend and if it extends
what is extending is a bunch of vectors
well you can tell they didn't try very
hard on the physical interpretations
because it always ends up with some
limitations yeah
anyways let's move on to the subject
matter today which is philosophy
and uh we don't do philosophy in this
channel good we're done
we do physics but we have to distinguish
philosophy from physics
and there's a lot of gray area because
philosophy has a long tradition dating
all the way at least till the greeks if
not earlier you know and so the problem
is that a lot of the subjects that
belong strictly to physics fell under
philosophy because the greeks treated
them under philosophy specifically
ontology what is ontology well it's the
study of existence to put it
succinctly okay
so but where do i have to start well i'm
gonna start a place that you might say
bill you're crazy why are you starting
here i'm gonna start at my heroes
okay
and because it's got a little bit of
context in what i'm gonna say today i'm
gonna start at who my heroes were when i
was a kid okay
and i'm talking about when i was about
15 years old i got into communism okay
and uh
i was head over heels with communism
right
and these were my heroes you know marx
lennon and fidel castro
and these heroes lasted in my heart for
about 25 years you couldn't find uglier
pictures of them
and then uh and then what happened well
uh eventually you know i grew out of
them
okay
and uh i had other heroes and these were
two other heroes natalie murray o'hare
who was the founder of american atheist
and carl sagan which was also an atheist
and i grew out of atheism as well so
these two stop being my heroes
specifically sagan because uh sagan just
had nonsense even indian in his
extraterrestrial stuff you know the the
fact that he wanted to uh be in contact
with another civilization and travel
through the stars and etc well all that
was nonsense together with you know what
he proposed which was quantum mechanics
and general relativity so you know i
have no uh
no fondness anymore of mr sagan uh he i
think he was an excellent teacher but he
was a lousy
uh we can call physicist
if if i call him math magicians
mathematics okay
now he actually do mathematics yeah yeah
he yeah yeah he was uh he did uh
mathematics okay i also had these two
guys which was babe ruth and uh hank
aaron and i grew out of them and they
were my heroes when i was a kid i was
specifically collecting baseball cards
but they stopped being my heroes simply
because i stopped paying attention to
baseball and moved on to soccer my point
here is that you know we all have our
heroes
especially when we're young they could
be your father and mother for all we
know you know they could be maybe a
teacher whoever
and
sometimes we grow out of them and we
grow out of them mainly because we find
something different in life maybe
throughout education experience whatever
you want to call it you know you go
through life and then you start changing
your mind about things
and i changed my mind about communism i
changed my mind about atheism
and uh about baseball
okay
so
yeah keep that in mind today okay
because i'm gonna get back to that issue
okay but let's start with uh i'm going
to start with one of the questions that
someone made okay regarding philosophy
this is what we'll start and he said uh
uh so to say here philosophy is equal
anthropology biology sociology
psychology i'm a bit lost
and
all i can say there is that you know
there are aspects
of anthropology that fall under physics
and aspects which fall under philosophy
for this we're going to need to define
what philosophy is to know what aspects
of a given discipline fall under one or
the other okay
so uh before you reach a conclusion say
what do you mean uh
philosophy includes anthropology and
biology and everything now let's let's
wait till we have a definition then
we'll be able to
pigeonhole these things and put them in
the right place okay did you tell them
the fight we had two days ago
we always argue before we come here day
one that i got here we started
just tearing the walls down about this
topic he wanted to destroy my my notion
of philosophy i would not let him no i
thought i won i won that discussion you
know
i i vote for my version
anyways um here's a another individual
uh
they came in there with an
issue that essentially triggered the
discussion today okay
and says the following uh she referring
to ain rand ayn rand as some people call
it i call aim rand uh was a philosopher
and the best one at that well again uh
we won't know until we define the word
philosophy we won't know who a
philosophy philosopher is until we
define what philosophy is that's
actually one of the questions what is
your
you gotta definition
a little patient well we'll get there
okay uh continuously she was dealing
referring to amran right she was dealing
with ideas morality and politics which
pertain only to human life and choice
yeah the issue is that morality and
politics are religion they fall under
really they don't fall under philosophy
at all as we will see today okay
once we define this word this key word
okay then we'll we'll be able to put in
the right cubbyhole that morality and
politics have nothing at all to do with
philosophy if that's what amran did
she was giving you recommendations she
was giving you her opinions and that's
how we define religion opinions beliefs
okay uh subjectivity okay
and rand was explaining the universe no
absolutely not even if she was which she
wasn't okay even she was then she would
be a physicist because if you explain
the universe meaning how the universe
works you are do you are doing physics
you're not doing philosophy again no
such thing as ontology no such thing as
epistemology there's only philosophy and
physics okay two branches as we will see
in a minute okay
uh but this is what we're gonna argue
okay there's only two branches one is
physics the other one's philosophy okay
and if you
are explaining how the universe works
you are squarely in the realm of physics
okay so if you say god made the universe
for example
you're not doing religion you're not
doing uh philosophy you're doing physics
you're telling me how the universe came
to be and i want a mechanism for you to
explain how the how god made the
universe okay we need to see the
mechanism okay now if you ask why did
god make the universe now you're talking
about philosophy because again it's as
we will see it deals with purposes and
reasons did you ever make the like
branch chart or the floating yeah we're
gonna see that in a minute uh anyways uh
two conscious entities she was
explaining the universe to conscious
enemies well who else are you gonna
explain it to if not to conscious
entities i mean uh do you explain you
can say
uh that you explain it to a dog okay and
a dog
sometimes we say the dog is conscious
but what we what we're saying when we
use it in that context we're saying it's
alive you know it's still conscious like
you know maybe it's had an accident and
sentient yeah right and we should not
confuse that with consciousness you know
human consciousness but if you don't
explain to a conscious individual who
else are you going to explain it i'm a
sleeping guy
he's not caught
unconscious dreams so yeah it's got to
be to a conscious person
okay so um
what's the problem the problem is that
no one has ever defined the word
philosophy in the last three thousand
years beginning with the greeks and
ending specifically with the stanford
encyclopedia of what philosophy here we
go with it
oh yes
give me a second here fell on the other
side sometimes it happens and you need a
better
yeah
you get a revenue just right okay
anyways this is from the dictionary.com
okay what is philosophy according to
dictionary okay this is our current
definition after 3 000 years this is
what we ended up with the rational
investigation of the truths
truth truths are beliefs you know what's
true to you is a lie to me okay oh boy a
lot of people have a fight i know i know
they're going to have
and principles of being knowledge or
conduct well knowledge is belief again
and uh conduct could be because now
we're talking about behavior but see
when you throw all these things in there
you say well it involves being and
knowledge and conduct and behavior when
you throw everything in there just to
cover all the bases it's easier to tear
your definition down you gotta limit
your wording so it doesn't it's not so
broad because when you make it so broad
then you can put in anything in there
you can say it deals with ontology
meaningless well one is that but it's
like god if god means everything then
god means nothing so you kind of have to
you know shorten the definition of god
if you're going to use them in some
rational way if you say god is
everything when you know then what is
god you know how can you use that
and then it's got two other definitions
there a particular system of thought
which is what most people understand by
philosophy it's his philosophy well
if that's the definition of the notion
you have a philosophy we have eight
billion philosophers on the planet
because everybody has a way of thinking
and recommendations of how you should
live and about politics and about
religion so if philosophy is just a way
of thinking it's it's a meaningless word
okay we all have a way of thinking and
then the other one is guidance in
practical affairs those are
recommendations and again it's like hey
this is how you should live this is who
you should vote for you know and that
sort of thing well those are opinions
and if it's opinions and
then when you say that you study
philosophy at the university
what do you really mean i mean what are
you studying are you studying
recommendations
hopefully you're studying something a
little more serious than just
an opinion a recommendation to someone
of how they should live who should they
should vote for or whatever that's
seriously a lot of people
i'm sorry that's serious to a lot of
people yeah you take that seriously well
yeah i know but my point is not
subjective you're not gonna stud this
one i'm saying if you go to the
university just study philosophy because
you're going to take all these courses
related to philosophy you cannot say
well i studied philosophy what did you
study well i studied recommendations
i mean hopefully every yeah but
everybody can have a recommendation no
problem there but what are you going to
do study recommendations i mean that's
what this will do yeah i know and this
is the problem this is why we that's why
i want to restrict the definition of uh
philosophy to that first one there to
conduct but i'm gonna just chop only
that piece in there that's what i'm
gonna be doing today okay whether you
like it or not well it turns into an
actual word because otherwise it has no
meaning if it has no borders if
philosophy covers all
subjects then what's the point of the
word in fact i'm going to get that oh
that's an important point that you make
if you go straight to behaviors and
conduct then you can
then we know we're talking about when we
say philosophy you're not talking about
biology you're not talking about
chemistry yeah yeah you're talking about
purposes
and reasons right
okay and this is the definition from the
wikipedia love of wisdom
you know what it meant i guess from the
greeks or how it was translated from the
greek love of wisdom you know what is
that i i love to be wise i mean i love
wise men
what does that mean and then you see the
word wisdom at the bottom
uh also i think from the wikipedia and
is associated with attributes such as
and they give one unbiased judgment you
know that's like uh
biased judgment isn't it
yeah it's an oxymoron because uh they're
both uh opinions
unbiased is unbiased means that you're
biased that's what unbiased means no
judgment
well but both of them really because
unbiased means that i mean what is there
that is unbiased
is it's just the opposite of bias which
means it's the same thing
i mean you know
are we saying objective judgment how can
there be an objective judgment
so that's definitely an oxymoron by his
judgment the whole point of judgment is
one thing is better than the other how
do you know that if you're not biased
then you have self-knowledge knowledge
is belief i covered that in the past a
lot of people don't like that but yeah
knowledge is belief in fact uh plato
defined it justified true belief or
that's how it was translated that's what
came to our days from plato the
interpretation of plato that he was
saying justified true belief that's what
knowledge is and that last word belief
means that knowledge is a synonym of
belief and i've gone through that in the
past a lot of people don't like it but
that's the bottom line until you can
come up with a better mousetrap that's
that stays air you're saying uh belief
and knowledge are the same when i know
something like i knew i knew for a fact
that communism was right and i knew it
for a fact
that lasted 25 years then my knowledge
went away well that's a good point i i i
once had me my brother and i once had a
big discussion with friends of ours
and
my brother really got a good good one on
them where he was talking about the
i mean
flat earth i mean now no i think you're
saying about columbus
going to the new world where everyone
knew that there that nothing was over
there
until we knew they found someone
thinking
so it's like how do we know or do we not
know is it a belief you know all that
stuff
anyways uh
these definitions are not solid
absolutely not and if this is what came
up what we came up with after 3000 years
we don't really have a good definition
of philosophy
so if if we're going to decide whether
for example in rand or aristotle
were
philosophers let's first define
philosophy
in a rational scientific
manner in a way that we can use it
consistently right
uh so that we can say yeah this guy was
a philosopher this guy was not i'll give
you because otherwise we're all
philosophers i'll give my two cents at
the end yeah to not to not you know
which okay
okay so what is the problem the problem
is we have not defined uh uh as as i'm
gonna argue today we have not defined
philosophy in 000 years in a way that is
scientific in the way we can use it
consistently in a way that you can
actually say that when you go to the
university
you study philosophy and you come out
being a philosopher for example right
just an example uh and so we're going to
say that enrand or aristador were
philosophers we had better know what
that word means okay
okay and
just in case here's the uh contrast with
physics which also has no definition
today we we're defining philosophy and
physics okay because those are the two
words that we're going to be looking at
are contrasting today and what you look
it up in the wikipedia says physics
science that studies well we already got
a problem with studies because anybody
can study and not know anything you
study for the test you get a zero on on
friday so
you know what does study mean does a
two-year-old who studies you know
his blocks or whatever is he a scientist
or a physicist yep so studies matter
okay matter
you're close okay it's motion and
behavior uh yeah okay you're close again
but then we have a process through space
and time
well we cannot travel through
concepts okay try traveling through uh
love for example okay see if you can do
that no you can't travel through space
and time so they shouldn't use that word
through ever for space and time because
space and time are not physical objects
and it says under related entities of
energy and force no energy and force are
not entities entities are objects things
those words mean are synonyms and energy
and force are something else there are
concepts
okay and so uh no physics we do not
study energy and we do not study force
time mass or charge or any of those
concepts okay we don't study love we
don't study intelligence we don't study
um
consciousness none of those things not
everything you can just stop it we don't
study
we don't study that explains a lot we
never study we never study okay never
these books are just for a show back
here
okay so uh let's get to the stanford
encyclopedia philosophy and here you
have it uh i know this is gonna shock
some of you but
it's called the stanford encyclopedia
philosophy probably the number one uh
reference site on the internet for
philosophy that's what's called the
encyclopedia of philosophy and this is
the page
you can look it up you don't have to
believe me but this is what you'll find
you'll find all these words are in
alphabetical order and what is missing
is the word philosophy you will not find
the word philosophy defined in the
stanford encyclopedia of philosophy okay
so uh it gives you an idea how how
important these words are for
for philosophers that they never define
what philosophy is i think they just
gave up they're like yeah it's too hard
yeah too many things in it but then
there's another notion that people have
of what philosophy is okay and they call
it the mother of all sciences
and this is uh an analysis that a foul
did in quora i liked it so i'm gonna put
it up here it says what the question was
why is philosophy the mother of all
science and this fellow answers
philosophy is not a science at all okay
according to today okay to what we have
today the the definition or the notion
we have the connection between science
and philosophy is historical not
conceptual at one time the natural
sciences were considered a branch of
philosophy called natural um
philosophy the idea that natural
philosophy was somehow replaced by
science is total bs
natural philosophy is simply what
natural sciences used to be called
philosophy could be considered the
mother of all science for historical
reasons but not for scientific or
philosophical ones under modern
understandings of these terms
okay so this notion that people have
that oh philosophy is the mother of all
science it precedes science because you
have to do some kind of thinking well
again it's because they never defined
the word philosophy first of all it's a
historical issue and it's very poetic
it does not mean
that it's rational that it has any
foundation whatsoever
okay so when people say uh that
philosophy is the mother of all sciences
you're talking poetry
that's it and they're not talking any
sensible thing
okay so what is philosophy let's get to
it
and for this we have to define science
first because we're going to include
philosophy under science it's one of the
two branches of science okay
according to you yeah this is according
to this site okay
science rational explanations very short
definition the longer you make the
easier it is to tear apart so never
define words crucial words the
foundations of in this case science uh
with lots of words the more words you
put in there the easier it's gonna be to
tear apart because there's gonna be
exceptions that's the problem
so what is physics one of the branches
well physics is rational explanations of
phenomena
and what is yeah of things that occur
right and then philosophy is the
rational explanations of behaviors okay
that's how we're going to divide this
we're going to limit it just to
behaviors
in the case of physics we have causes
and mechanisms and in the case of
philosophy we have reasons and purposes
why someone does something okay and
again the bread and butter of physics is
the object you need to have objects and
the bread and butter of
philosophy you could say is the concept
okay in general terms
so that's how we're gonna
branch these things out we're gonna uh
define them very specifically so that we
can use them consistently okay
that's that's where where i'm headed
okay so uh
if those are the definitions
we've never had philosophers on planet
earth
okay
not one not one
because what were they supposed to do
they were supposed to explain behaviors
now i can't say we've never had any
philosophers i'm saying that all the
traditional philosophers were not
philosophers maybe a psychologist is a
philosopher because he's got to explain
you know a behavior of maybe one of his
patients or a psychiatrist or whatever
so so he's a true philosopher but
they're not considered philosophers the
philosophers are those people who talk
about the existence and all this other
stuff which has nothing to do with
philosophy and has all to do with
physics okay and so all these people
that we have here okay
that i put up the other day uh
uh plato aristotle all the greeks in
general okay uh all the way to
enran and uh sartre john paul sartre and
uh thomas [ __ ] none of these were
philosophers they would they did not do
philosophy because they never explained
anything i'd like to
do an analogy and saying that uh this is
essentially uh the mary poppins version
okay and uh there's a
part in mary poppins where mr banks you
know the banker he says will you be good
enough to explain all this talking to
mary poppins and she says first of all i
would like to make one thing perfectly
clear and mr banks says yes
and mary poppins says i never explain
anything and that essentially
synthesizes okay
what we have today we don't have
explanations either from physics or from
philosophy
okay so that's why i'm saying that we
had
no philosophers at least the traditional
ones that's what i'm really referring to
well again and i could make an exception
and say that psychologists and maybe
psychiatrists people like that they are
the true genuine philosophers because
they try to explain behavior it could be
also veterinar veterinarian i mean and
looks at an animal says the reason this
animal behaves this way in that way and
he gives a reason then is also a
philosopher okay in that in that context
that's where i'm gonna limit philosophy
one portion of the broad notion that we
have today of uh
a philosophy okay so i'm gonna chop it
off there
and uh so yeah under that definition
uh we can reject traditional
philosophers including in ranch he was
not a philosopher now this person gave
in a couple
one example and i'm going to analyze
that example to show you also
why we need to separate physics from
philosophy and this person said objects
exist independent of consciousness is
what she says meaning enrand okay
and no that's not what she said that's
not what aim ran said at all okay i want
to make sure that people understand that
and ran did not say that what did ayn
rand say and she said the following okay
she said
to exist is to be something
and i'm saying no she missed something
now it's something plus location that's
what exist means because the word exists
belongs exclusively to physics and not
at all to philosophy when you have
philosophers who venture into physics
not knowing that they cross the line and
they still think they're doing
philosophy well we have a problem
because we we need to define chop off
the word philosophy so it does not
encroach on physics and say well we're
doing ontology no no such monster you
either do physics like mr rutherford
says or you do stamp collecting okay
and so uh the word exists belongs
exclusively to physics and it's defined
as something plus
location it's got to have location
but here's what ain't used to say this
is out of her books okay perceive she
talked about perceiving things entities
okay again not awareness of entities
sight and touch
again we remove the observer in science
especially in
i'm sorry in physics
we don't use the observer we kill the
witness
mafia style okay no one is allowed to
testify
something exists which one what
perceives absolutely not existence and
consciousness are axioms you cannot
escape no consciousness has nothing at
all to do with existence not at all we
don't care what you perceive you could
be drunk you could be on um on steroids
whatever up your uh
head you know so
uh no we don't use consciousness at all
for existence a thing is itself
existence is identity well you can
say that a is a meaning a ball is a ball
no problem but that doesn't
define existence existence you need
location as well that's what she missed
and something needs sight and or touch
absolutely not yeah we don't use the
observer we don't use sight we don't use
touch we don't use any of the senses
except common sense the least common of
all senses and again she talked about
perceiving entities so no uh the problem
with ayn rand she introduced the
observer and when she does that she goes
into religion she goes into subjectivity
and not into physics
exists belongs exclusively to physics
that word belongs there and they're
alone and so here's the definition of
exists so that we can compare it against
what the iran proposed exists is
physical presence very short definition
we keep it as short as we can
what is physical object what is presence
location okay what is an object that
would just shape what is location the
set of distances to all other objects
that exist okay that are there and so if
god wants to exist
first god has to be an object a thing he
can't be a concept you can't say god is
love god is spirit no god has to be an
object so you can say god is a man looks
like a man uh arm's head whatever you
know okay then we have an object so far
so good but you're not done
god has to have
distance with respect to everything
every atom in the universe that means no
matter what something that exists has to
be able to answer the question how far
is it from me
no because how far is a question of math
uh uh this is all quality is something
but it's some but it that has an answer
it's not yeah yeah but this at the end
this is like this is what number it is
doesn't matter i'm just saying it's a
binary it either has
some distance to me or it doesn't yeah
for that again we define distance as
separation there is a separation between
my chest and god's chest one and then
there's a line of direction
between me and god god can hide in any
dimension you want he can go to the 26th
dimension of string theory okay we don't
care there's got to be a straight line
of direction from me to him wherever he
wishes to hide
if we can't do that he does not exist by
definition because he does not have
location okay that's the way we look at
it so it's got to have two things got to
be an object it's got to have location
what is location the set of distances to
all atoms
in in the universe okay in existence
okay so here are the foundations of
physics okay to separate from philosophy
these are words that belong exclusively
to physics and not at all to philosophy
anyone touching these words whether they
know it or not they cross the line into
physics okay these are the foundations
of physics and i haven't covered every
word but just the most important ones
here they go
object
distance location
motion exist and space those words form
the foundations of physics they have
nothing at all to do with philosophy we
do not deal with entities which is what
ain't ran tried to define we she does
she dealt with existence not only did
she misdefine it because she was not a
she was not into physics didn't realize
that she crossed the line into physics
and yeah hopefully she tried to explain
to a conscious person that doesn't
change anything okay
so these words belong exclusively to
physics they do not belong to
uh philosophy at all
okay so anyone touching these words
whether they know it or not they cross
the line into physics and they are no
longer a philosopher or they're not
doing philosophy
okay and uh final issue before my son
here kills me okay uh
here we have the fallacies if you're
gonna define okay if you're gonna define
the word philosophy first of all keep it
short
very brief that's my strong
recommendation the more words you put in
there the more if ands and buts
uh the more bases you try to cover the
worse it is because it's complicated
yeah yeah well you the more complicated
you make it
the easier it's going to be to tear down
for someone who wants to challenge you
okay keep that in mind that's my
recommendation right friendlier way to
say it is the harder it is to understand
also also yeah but these are the
fallacies you can't use any of these
fallacies because those are not valid
arguments to defend your definition
they're the fallacies of authority of
democracy and of tradition what is
authority well my teacher told me this
is what i learned in college or in high
school
she knows a lot of things so she must
have yeah yeah i mean the fact that this
is how you were raised or maybe your
parents told you this and you say well i
think my
my folks were right you know uh a better
way to say you can't use it like that
you can't use it as an argument that's
one of them the better way to say it is
they're right about the first nine
things why wouldn't they be right about
the tenth one yeah but again uh
i'm sure marx was very right about
communism but uh i i kind of got away
from that
uh fallacy of democracy the fact that
everybody on earth votes for the flat
earth does not make it so okay so the
fact that more people raise their arms
and say say oh mathematical physics is
right
it doesn't make it so
two plus two equals five doesn't matter
how many people yeah vote for it you can
you could be in an asylum and all the
you know crazy people they vote for
whatever and you say well but you're all
crazy yeah but you're a majority and so
what are you gonna do and then the
tradition the fact that oh we've always
done it that way since the days of the
greeks that's what philosophy has always
been you're gonna change that now bill
uh and what i can tell you there there
is the following all these words that i
mentioned earlier
they're up for grabs no one has ever
defined them scientifically in the
history of life on earth and so they're
up for grabs you can find any
satisfaction
they're iraq it's easier to tear them
apart and so if you can tear them apart
then i don't care if they have tradition
i don't care if they have democracy
behind them or
or what was the authority uh it doesn't
make it so so these words are up for
grabs because no one has really defined
them scientifically everybody uses the
word the definition they find in the
ordinary dictionary which is no of no
use
if you bring them into physics because
now you're going to run into trouble
communicating
in a in a rational environment okay
that's why these words need new
definitions so these words are up for
grabs to say bill but we've had a long
tradition and everybody votes for them
and this is what they taught me in
college and high school
these are irrelevant arguments these are
not
the arguments that you can use they're
easy to tear apart okay
i pass the microphone to you if you want
to say anything beat me up
okay that's over now
i mean it's i don't know what i guess we
got a few questions here let's start off
with uh
your definition of philosopher
i'm sure you hit it at some point but
just to read it okay uh reiterate uh
philosopher let's go with philosophy
this would uh a person who does
philosophy would be a philosopher what
is philosophy philosophy is the um
explanation
remember it's got to be a rational
explanation of what in this case of
purposes and reasons of behaviors so so
and i'll give you an example okay um
napoleon you know uh
can we get a different example for once
it's always the bullying
yeah it's always napoleon
you know i mean why did he go to
waterloo how about that that's actually
how he asked why did he go to waterloo i
mean he went to fight a battle and you
say and you have different theories you
have different explanations one guy says
well he went to make money the other guy
says he wanted to be famous he wanted to
leave his legacy in the history book you
can have different uh
explanations okay rational explanations
and people listen to one listen to the
other and then people choose choosing is
religion you know you choose one theory
over another that's fine but this is
what this is what philosophy is okay
okay we had another one yeah i didn't
quite understand it but is and we'll get
to them okay is the ruler two things
because it measures
length
two things what do you mean two things
two things that was the question
i'm guessing since you can pick out two
points on a ruler
with oh
they talk about concepts because
concepts is a word that invokes or
embodies two objects i don't know if
that referring to that
a ruler is a physical object that's what
it is you point and say ruler but if
you're going to compare something and
you're going to say the front end of the
ruler against the back end of the ruler
you're talking about two points you're
now you have now you're not talking
about the ruler you're talking about the
ends of the ruler and you're treating
them as separate objects and now you
have a relation so
now you're talking about a concept so
the ruler is a physical object the two
endpoints of a ruler are and you're
making a relation between them then
you're talking about a concept
any motion by the way any type of motion
is a concept known as a dynamic concept
because you're gonna have two two
locations
or a comparison against another object
that's moving or or whatever or you're
gonna compare the motion the the
location of the object with respect to a
starting point so any motion is always a
concept and always a dynamic concept
does that mean when you're
for example in the case of the ruler you
can cut out a shape
any shape you want out of the ruler in
this case we're cutting out one end of
the ruler
and cutting on a different end of the
ruler and treating those two that's why
it's a separate object yeah
let's look at another word this is your
contextual right
direction
direction you can only have direction if
you have
passively implicitly right two points
so your direction implies or embodies
two objects okay you can't have
direction with just a single point okay
you need to have
by by uh the concept itself you know the
conceptual you need to have two objects
for direction uh this is a short one
um
are behaviors things
no of course not what's the difference
between a behavior and a thing then that
which has shape is a thing okay and uh
behavior
what uh you don't confuse it with
pattern okay behavior and pattern
people use the word pattern like he's a
he's got a pattern of behavior like you
know you've got a pattern of how you
behave or your comportment or whatever
uh that's different you know we're
talking about pattern like when you look
at a
you know an ice
or uh
i don't know for example a
piece of snow you know it's got that
little typical pattern well that's not
the same thing as pattern of behavior
okay so let's separate the word pattern
from one and the other which is probably
the context that this person is raising
it here because usually when you're
explaining someone's behavior you're
using a pattern of behavior
right something you've seen before right
but uh we're not drawing anything we're
saying that we're using the word pattern
only in the sense that this is the way
the guy behaves we call that a pattern
that's different than the pattern of a
uh you know an ice cube or whatever uh
snowflake
um you might have to redefine philosophy
in physics one more time because okay uh
is philosophy a super set or this is
more of a statement if uh philosophy is
a super set of physics according to your
definitions
philosophy is super ordinate to physics
physics would separate subordination
physics would be a branch of philosophy
according to your definitions why no i
think i made it clear but let's clarify
that just in case
science is the big one okay we're going
to put philosophy and physics under
science okay that's what we're going to
do here okay it doesn't mean you have to
agree but in science we do not agree and
we do not agree to disagree there's no
such thing as agreement in science in
science
we have to take shield and sword get
inside the ring and fight for our
definition
one person can remain standing only one
definition remains standing we can't
have two definitions for exist we can't
have two definitions for the word object
location etc only one definition remains
standing or else we want to understand
it right because then we're talking
across purposes but uh so what was the
issue again is philosophy okay
superordinate to physics yeah
what you have is uh
science and then on that you have two
branches one is physics that deals with
mechanisms and causes and philosophy
which deals with uh purposes and reasons
why someone does something has nothing
at all to do
let's clarify we're talking about people
well not necessarily it could be an
animal also but living things yeah let
me
i i think you're gonna exclude
a rock you're gonna you're gonna heal
you're gonna exclude you're gonna
exclude plants and rocks rolling down
the hill
or why the why the little airplane toy
airplane or the kite flew you know
that's physics well you can't say why in
the sense of
uh you can say uh why in the sense of
cause but not in the sense of purpose
when you say
why why did you fly a kite then you're
talking about the person okay why didn't
you exclude plants
uh because um you're talking about
purpose and i can't imagine uh
it's a living being
you could say that i think that's
physics now because if you're gonna say
that the plant behaves this and that
that way because the sun or whatever is
in contact with it or it reacts to the
sun now you're talking about physics
well but i can't i can't imagine a plant
having a purpose or a ring okay but if
we're going to go down that road then
there's people who believe in
determinism and according to determinism
everything would fall under physics
because it would just be a chain of
events of atoms bumping into each other
yeah and then explaining every behavior
as well in fact uh when you look at
determinism versus free will free will
is more like philosophy and determinism
more like physics okay because
determinism we're saying look
everything's already cut out
everything's every every atom is out
there you know and it happens in a
certain way like mr laplace said a
couple centuries ago
except you know if you you have to focus
or you have to separate what each atom
does
okay
from what the what the atoms produce
like the atoms in your brain the ones
that form the cells the thinking part
you know that's that's not physics uh
the physics is that you create the
thought somehow right uh electrochemical
processes that parts physics but the
thought itself you know uh why you think
this way or that way why you took this
decision instead of another that part
falls under philosophy
because now you're talking about
behavior purposes
this one comes from me
here we go
the show is over folks um killing the
witness
you often talk about killing the witness
but you also often use uh god's eyes
similar phrases when you're explaining
your things like let's imagine when you
use the word imagine you're implicitly
putting in an observer always
and that tends to confuse people how do
you it tends to confuse people that's
true because people confuse the
it's a thought experiment remember
because you're thinking about you
thinking or about someone else thinking
about god doing doing his thinking so
you're kind of putting words in god's
mind yeah so you're putting a person
there you're putting a person there a
third person you know so you're gonna
explain a phenomenon a mechanism but you
put god in there and
saying you know for example that he
created the universe but again uh we
have to separate what's going on in
god's mind from what comes out of his
magic wand the process the mechanism
that comes you know here here the magic
wand and we have a magic wand and so you
have to separate the mechanism of how he
created the universe from the why did he
do it what was his purpose what was his
reasoning
okay so yeah this is kind of what i was
going at uh someone says here you can
apply philosophy to plants for instance
fruit trees want its fruits to be eaten
since it will then propagated species
since the poop seeds will give more
fruit trees in the future the question
is is that a question of physics or
i mean does the plant do it consciously
or is it that this is how it evolved
you know like you have these uh plants
that eat insects right they're
carnivorous
carnivorous plants are known as you know
and so the issue is does the plant do it
consciously does it say oh i'm going to
trap that fly or is this a mechanism
that evolved over time a mechanism
against a
the way things developed in evolution
where you know maybe
i'll just give an example the fly just
uh fell in there tickled something in
there that triggered some uh spontaneous
reaction and this thing closed in and
they say i like the way i'm feeding
myself and uh obviously
they didn't do that but it's just a
mechanism it's just a trigger trap
it's uh it's like you know when when you
set a trap for for a mouse right you set
a trap the the trap is not thinking
as soon as the mouse steps on it the
trap hit you're thinking because you
want to catch the mouse you have a
purpose for that trap but the trap
itself has no it's just a mechanism well
actually uh there is a form of thought
that
that would
say that any form of reaction
is a type of consciousness when you hit
a bell and it goes bing
that's a very
basic form of consciousness they're
saying the bell is actually conscious
because it gives that reaction and our
sentience is just a high level order of
reaction we have just very complex
reactions so you're saying i hit a drum
right and it goes film that would count
as a low level consciousness
because it's a reaction i mean uh i
think you're gonna get a lot of problems
you're gonna get a level of trouble if
you start defining things that way every
thump
uh every ring every whatever uh is it's
like pocahontas is the rockstar
consciousness beginning of uh
consciousness you know or of uh some
kind of purpose but it just goes to the
point where where the more you delve
into it either you say everything has
consciousness even the bells and the
rocks or nothing does and it's all
deterministic and we're all just a chain
reaction of atoms but that gets into
weird well one of the biggest things to
keep in that train of thought is how
life developed you know here you have
objects
atoms right and they form these dna
strings right
and somehow that
morphed into something that crawled out
of the ocean
inanimate yeah and so you went from
physics to something that's thinking or
that has a cpu central processing unit
that controls each one of the
compartments of a cell which
apparently is the
unit of life the unit of life is the
cell whether plant or animal the unit is
the cell but what is a cell a cell is a
compartmentalized
entity
and you can say it has thinking it has i
don't know if it has purpose
exactly there if that arises later but
certainly it has some kind of thinking
because it's organized in such a way
that it knows that it's got to move this
thing that thing there and it controls
it all from a central again central
processing unit and how did all these
atoms which are just atoms i mean we're
atoms also
and if you cut us into little pieces you
eventually end up with a bunch of little
marbles known as atoms right and so all
these things put together make something
that now takes a life of lit takes a
life and is very interested in keeping
moving for some reason like we really
don't want to die we really like moving
speak for yourself okay get the the best
question for last this is this was the
one that i kept to tear down everything
you talked about okay so if you have a
question jamie little timmy comes along
and has a question
why does the category of the question
matter
whether it's philosophy religion or
physics why does that matter at all to
this question well i think we need to
separate in order to
have a rational conversation if i'm
going to explain a mechanism that should
not be confused with a reason that's
what i'm saying and so somehow i have to
separate those two reason or purpose
from
mechanism and cause are you saying we
have to find out what they're asking
no no what i'm saying is if the person
is asking a question right the first
thing i need to do is pitch and hold it
to find out are you asking
a question of reason and purpose you
know why god created the universe if he
had a headache maybe that day that's one
issue or is it are you talking how did
he do it what was the mechanism so first
of all i need to again pigeonhole it you
know i need to put it in the right uh
cubby hole that's just knowing what
they're asking no because if i'm going
to give if if i give you um an
explanation of mechanism because that's
what you're asking that's what you want
to understand right then i give you a
mechanism but if you say why did you oh
that's that's a different story now you
want a different type of question
answered and so allah i'm saying is all
questions can be divided in those two
categories we call one physics the other
one philosophy now a lot of people are
going to say again bill i don't like
your your definition of philosophy maybe
even a physics
no problem you don't have to agree to my
definition all i'm saying is
the way it works in science you get to
get inside the ring and fight for your
definition you cannot say that's how we
always done it authority i'm sorry um
tradition that's how my teacher taught
me that's how that's what everybody
votes for none of those are valid
arguments you need to get inside the
ring get a definition that we can use
consistently well i just take it a step
further and say there is no purpose
to defining philosophy or science
because that never answers a question
that anyone needs answered
if timmy has a question it doesn't
matter if you call it philosophy banana
or science
answer the kid's question well i need to
know what is that what do you want to
know yeah yeah but it doesn't matter
what your category is it turns out it
turns out that when answering the
question of magnetism
uh richard feynman you can look it up on
youtube uh he said
what is it that you want to know when
the when the reporter says
how does a magnet attract another
question
what is it that you want to know
he's asking
he's answering with the question and
that's true okay let me get to the
moonies okay oh let's keep going yeah
yeah we're going a little bit i don't
want to lose the moonies because there
were lots of questions on the moon but
we're going to go relatively quickly
who are the moonies
running out of paper
okay uh the moonies who are the moonies
moonies are people who uh
believe that we did not land on the moon
okay so they don't make that assumption
they don't accept this without their
yeah
okay so here's uh here's uh one uh one a
couple of
issues that these people raised not only
with respect to the moon but with
respect to the iss which i raised as an
issue and a couple others like the
challenger and the columbia disasters
here's the question one fellow just says
we didn't go bill
that's you haven't said anything you
just give me your opinion um unless you
fill that up with a little more we have
nothing are you even addressing that
well no but a lot of people make
comments like that and you know
i mean i think some of these people are
just wasting their time won't even write
four words when you said absolutely
nothing just gave an opinion you just
voted that's all you did that's religion
then another fellow says why on earth do
you still believe in a retro reflector
on the moon
well the first thing you have to
understand is that you do not need
humans
in this case uh apollo 14 and 15
where they placed
allegedly for those who believe we went
to the moon that that's when they placed
the retro reflector on the moon okay uh
but the russians put a retro reflector
on the moon without ever putting a human
on them a russian you know on the moon
they did it all artificially with you
know robots so the first thing you have
to understand you do not you do not need
a human to go in there and put that
little device on the moon okay and so
the only question there is did
did we ever send a rocket to the moon
any probe or anything that's the issue
okay so forget about humans if you're
thinking about a human placing it there
that's all i'm saying here and then the
other nfl said with technology being
what it is today holographic projections
could be quite convincing on a scale we
are unaware exists
okay this guy's just putting things
beyond our reach saying well we don't
know all the
things that they have out there so maybe
it happened maybe he did not he's
referring to the iss
he's saying that it could be a hologram
they're so good at faking things we'll
never know anything is true yeah so they
gave up yeah well yeah that's all
they're doing they're putting it beyond
the reach
it's like saying well we don't know
everything you know and so by doing so
they're just putting up beyond the reach
whatever you answer he's going to say
well we don't know him he just gave up
yeah that's all he's saying but all i'm
saying here is that that thing up there
hopefully it's not a hologram i mean if
you can't tell the difference between a
hologram
and the real device when you focus you
know with your
binoculars okay these are
pair of binoculars okay i encourage
people to buy them or a telescope and
you'll see the iss up there with your
own eyes you do not have to believe it's
there or or you'll see some of the
arguments people made on whether the iss
is up there to begin with why would they
how
i mean you know how why would they spend
so much money to even make a hologram
assuming you were a hologram you know
how hard it would be to they said for no
reason we just have a hologram going
around earth no doing just a trick one
imagine imagine what that is a hologram
would be focused from the ground right
some kind of laser whatever and you
focus it at the sky but imagine now that
from
maybe it's from a satellite no no
because they don't believe in saturn
right i know that's what i mean maybe
is this a car that's going really fast
or a flight like why would they bother
well they say they're trying to fool us
all these uh people who govern the world
you know they're trying to
oz has a lot of work to do
yeah anyways uh one individual says what
does the iss existing have to do with
the moon landings and another fellow
says the isis is not the moon why the
reference
and so we have to uh these folks did not
uh listen to the whole thing obviously
they just got a piece we have to go
there first okay
and i'll go with before we get to the
moon let's start with orbeez
let me go with uh let's go back to
napoleon okay here here's the here's the
million dollar question for you
can you prove that napoleon went to
waterloo
okay can you prove that to whom
uh to me to a conscious person like this
well sometimes i'm conscious
can you prove that
what are you gonna put i mean you're
going to bring that history book and say
well this is what i studied in high
school or college or whatever is that
what you're going to tell me that it's
in the book that's like saying uh well
the bible says such and such thing i
mean so what are we supposed to do just
to believe
what's in a book
okay so all i'm saying you cannot prove
that napoleon went to waterloo even even
if you went there and filmed it
let's say you time traveled maybe uh you
were one of those few people who
invented the
uh camera in 1815 so you had the camera
there
who would believe you you said i filmed
it look here it is here's napoleon
and well let's assume you filmed it you
bring it back and i say well that's a
fake
i don't believe you
what are you going to do
you say that was done in hollywood
i mean you can go on and on and on
there's no way to prove that napoleon
went to waterloo or caesar went to
england or you know the problem there is
the word prove but that's a separate
issue well again because again proof is
belief that means we accept we are
conservatives
on the basis of belief we're saying well
it's been passed
through tradition
right from one generation to the next
and we have no reason to doubt that but
imagine if you had to prove it to an e.t
you know he comes here the earth and you
say look napoleon went to waterloo in
1815. and the guy says uh prove it
what are you gonna do well here's the
book here's the history book you know
yeah okay so it's like you always say
proof is convincing proof is persuasion
yeah
the indians used to pass it by word of
mouth we invented writing and we pass it
by writing but we don't believe it yeah
and so if you cannot prove to me if you
cannot prove to me that napoleon went to
waterloo let's now put it in the context
of the moon landing can you prove to me
right without repeating the uh
the
occasion the phenomenon that uh neil
armstrong put his foot on the moon are
you a moony
uh well no no but i'm kidding
can you prove to me what happened in
1969 all i can show you you know is a
movie
a film right maybe some documents
whatever that's all i can show you i can
try to prove to you through
uh documents through film through
whatever through maybe testimony
that
neil armstrong went to the moon okay but
i can't reproduce the event again okay
and say look i'm going to show you that
in 1969 neil armstrong stopped on the
moon here's neil armstrong and let me
show you how he did it you know i can't
do that and and so now let's get to
where i'm i'm headed these guys asked
how about the iss well the iss is going
up there right now this very moment
so we're not talking about 1969
so forget about 1969 because i can't
prove it to you and like i say you can't
tell the difference between hollywood
let's assume we had all the technology
we have today that we had in 1969 then
they could have reproduced anything that
you can imagine
uh like landing on the moon they could
have reproduced it in hollywood just as
well how can you tell the difference now
between the real thing armstrong
actually stepping on the moon
and these guys doing it in hollywood
okay you can't tell the difference
because you won't believe it one way or
another because we're already too
knowledgeable too savvy to to
intelligent have too much wisdom on how
these things are done we've also been
burned so many times by government so we
have all these conspiracy things in our
heads right because we don't want to
believe in anything anymore you know and
so the issue is what the issue is that
uh i can't tell the difference between
the real thing
and something made in hollywood anymore
i can't do that scaring me okay so so if
you can't tell the difference it's not
an argument against
the fact that we went on the moon so if
if neil armstrong actually stepped on
the moon you can't say well you know
that could have been done in hollywood
yes of course it or not yeah
that doesn't change the fact that he
actually did step on the moon if he did
right so you're not going to use that as
an argument now another of the arguments
some of the people made here is that oh
look at all the errors in fact let me
get to some of those okay uh here's one
uh here's a couple actually here's one
okay
and this fall lists all these things
questions that have to be answered and
he lists all these questions what
materials can withstand the temperature
etcetera etcetera i think he was
referring to the iss here but again he
asked all these questions and i'm saying
all you need to do is get a pair of
binoculars don't ask these questions get
a pair of binoculars you have the
schedule from nasa this thing passes uh
around the earth 15 to 16 times a day
every hour and a half over your skies if
it's not in your region ask your friend
who lives in illinois or in germany or
wherever to look it up and say does the
iss pass through there and the guy will
say yes or no and so if it's a no he
said no it didn't pass through here so
it's a hoax but if he says it's there
well now you have at least that part you
covered that base you crossed that t you
dotted that eye but you know why ask all
these questions it's much easier to go
out there and get one of these you know
about pair by inaccuracies and just
point it at the sky and see if you can
see it okay
but uh here was i think it's uh this one
here
give me a second here let me look at oh
here it is
here it is
this is uh this is what a lot of people
have out there okay that a lot of people
have
they're reasoning along these lines and
what this guy says look he put all this
he says the earth is not gray it is
brown okay astronauts hanging off wires
uh should have been uh faster he says
instead of slow motion uh but you would
jump higher and he goes through all
these little things that are wrong of
what he sees in the movies that are
shown um you know to the world and the
problem i've got here is that you know
imagine you make a movie of the romans
fighting you know in uh 2000 years ago
okay so
so here you're gonna you're the director
of the movie and the guy's fighting with
a sword and shield and he's got a rolex
watch
well that's kind of like an era i think
you want to cut that out of your movie
right and then the scenery is pagodas
you know japanese pagoda so we've got a
problem because you know that's the
wrong scenery sounds like an awesome
movie so so yeah but but then you have
so many errors do you think the
directors professional people would have
made so many errors
i mean they made that many errors in 911
you believe it was a conspiracy
yeah but
they made it
but the question is yeah because they
did make all these but see if if you
make all these errors if you make all
these errors then then you say well hold
it uh
you mean they made this this movie and
they had so many errors and nobody
none of the directors caught any of this
stuff you know they were wearing the
wrong pants they were wearing jeans
instead of you know
whatever they were in those days
we've got a problem so the more errors
you find the less your argument holds
okay they could have not made all those
errors now if you find one little tiny
air and say oh look this shadow was
wrong and you just hang on that one well
that's a different story but when you
say the shadow's wrong the stars in the
background are wrong uh the the earth is
wet brown instead of green or whatever
but isn't that uh you know when you find
so many errors then obviously something
is wrong with your reasoning it couldn't
have been so many errors but that
argument sounds like the fallacy of
authority you're supposing that the
directors are competent i am supposing
that they will not make so many errors
they would have checked all this
stuff going to do this many directors
well yeah but now again and you got all
these experts there and they say look
we're going to show this to the world we
better do it right so okay so check the
lighting here check the shadows check
the stars in the back they would have
checked everything
maybe they missed one you know that
could have been it you know
it could have happened if they filmed it
in hollywood but they could have missed
so many if they missed so many as
something is wrong with your reasoning
okay that's what i'm saying okay
okay here's uh
getting back to the iss again the iss is
something you can show right now so
forget about the moon landings if if if
you don't believe in the iss that's out
there forget about the moon landing
you're not gonna believe that one at all
okay so let's get to the that's why i
say the iss the iss is a big monster
that it's up there
and you can see it with the binoculars
you can tell the tell how big it is
okay you if you don't know how to
calculate that go to your friendly
mathematician he'll go in there and
he'll make all these calculations for
you and tell you look it's so big it's
so far out they can do all that so it's
got so much mass okay they can do all
that stuff so you know if if you see it
out there and
and you've got all these this
information
then you say okay there is this monster
floating out there it's orbiting around
the earth how did it get up there
hopefully hopefully we went through
several stages several steps
and among them you have to include
rockets that take things out into space
near space but you know uh it is uh
within you know uh certain of 400
kilometers that's where it is but
it's something that um it had to take
several steps to make you could have the
first day just send a couple rockets and
then the whole thing up there catapults
yeah in fact uh in fact the uh iss took
10 years to build piece by piece
according to the government right but
see uh
they had to take it with a shuttle and
so on so if you're gonna go through all
that obviously you gotta say well hold
it they built the shuttle how did they
build the shuttle they built it from one
day to the next they just took out what
a 747 turned it into a shuttle is that
how it was no they had to
go through all these steps where they
built one device then made it more
complicated until they eventually
reached the iss which you can prove is
out there floating in the middle of
nowhere okay so this is all i'm saying
that this is something you can verify
today for yourself without having to
uh wait for the government to feed the
hoax to lie to you that's what i'm
saying saying you can say that men did
not land on the moon because you don't
trust the government to tell you the
truth fine no fake news you know but iss
is one of those things you do not have
to wait for the government to tell you
anything you can verify for yourself so
if you're concerned about if you really
want to get to the bottom of it get a
pair of binoculars we're done okay and
so this all says the following he says
watch a 747 a cruise altitude with
binoculars okay then observe the iss
with binoculars okay then think about
that we are told that the iss is 408
kilometers away and it's only
approximately double the size of the
747. the 747 is only around 10
kilometers away now the in other words
this thing is 40 times farther out and
so here are the measurements okay with
respect to a football field you can see
the 747 is a little smaller but there
are 747s that grew a little bigger after
this so
the length that you see there is not the
one for the picture but it gives you an
idea how big some of these 747s are and
they're just about as big as the iss
okay so one is 70 meters the other one
is 73 meters the wings bang one is uh
what 68 and the other one is what um
uh 109 meters and so on so you know
they're approximately the same or maybe
you know the iss is a little bigger but
they're big okay
but what's the issue the issue is here
you have
the distance okay this is what they look
like more or less okay
the plane on the left is not really at
ten thousand meters that's what what i
think but you can see that with your own
eyes you don't need binoculars for that
okay the one on the right which is the
iss
you know that's a uh
that's seen through a telescope
okay or maybe well yeah i think it's a
telescope in this case and i showed this
other one which is this um
uh amateur and he filmed it and here you
see his film of the iss in the sky this
is what it looks like he's looking at
that he's focused he's
photographing that in other words he's
filming that through his telescope okay
so he's he's looking through the
telescope that's how he gets that and
you can see the image on the bottom
right there that's what it looks like in
the best of cases so it does look like a
monster but he sees it very lightly he
sees it very blurry so
you know you're not you're not comparing
uh making a fair comparison when you say
an uh 747 versus the iss when you're
looking at the airplane you can see it
with your your own eyes you know you
practically don't need um binoculars on
the iss you do need binary you can't see
it with your own eyes okay i think maybe
maybe someone might see a dot in the sky
on a clear day could be i don't know
uh do have i
seen the iss up there
any more than i've seen santa claus at
the north pole i have not gone to the
north pole to see if santa claus is
there
because i don't think i need to verify
that specific issue and likewise i don't
think uh yeah well maybe i can look at
him from from here maybe he's at the
north pole you know but likewise uh i
have no doubt that the iss is out there
okay
but if you have doubts we'll
kill your doubt uh find out if the iss
is out there you know that's all you
have to do
okay here's another phone he says buzz
aldrin flipped the torch around in low
earth orbit he talks about hanging on
wires fake footage
bubbles underwater training exercises
saying that he saw bubbles come out of
the suit and he says that uh was from
underwater you know so uh in other words
that was filmed underwater they come up
with all these uh ideas and all i'm
saying is forget about buzz aldrin do do
the iss okay and uh you know if if
you're going to
try to show to yourself right verify for
yourself that the iss is out there then
you have to explain that you're going to
have to say how did that thing get up
there how did they put it up there did
they do it in one day or were there
previous steps and that'll get you
thinking that yeah we had to have
certain rockets before we could send
that thing up there and that'll get you
into the program
that says yeah we are sending things out
into space among them satellites for
those who believe in satellites a lot of
flat earthers don't because they don't
want to believe in satellites because if
they believe in satellites then you can
take a picture of the earth from a
satellite and you would
show that their
flat earth notion is wrong so they begin
by denying that we have even
you know uh satellites out there but
then you know uh how we communicate
what's this uh
uh phone that we have that you know that
collects all this stuff is that done
through little wires how are you doing
today little people little fairies and
the electronics yeah i mean these people
really got out of their way sometimes
okay and again the guy says filming the
iss takes almost zero resource and
energy because some people say well why
don't they have some
more films of the iss and so on and this
fellow said well you know you don't you
don't need a big thing there to you know
like building when they built the iss
imagine what that is these people are
out there trying to build the iss and
they're going to have just one guy out
there you know in the middle of nowhere
saying let me film the the construction
of this okay
i don't know maybe they do have it maybe
they don't i have no idea but i don't
think it's a requirement that they would
have filmed it okay but some people
expect that to have happened and they
said i don't see any film of them
building it so it never happened
don't tell me that tell me if you have a
pair by now
if the thing is up there that's all you
have to tell me you know is it out there
or not because again we have people with
different levels of belief of
assumptions out there some people don't
believe any at all others say well there
is this up there but there's no people
in it others say well there's people in
it but they're not floating around and
so you have all these different levels
so forget about the moon landing some
people have problems with what is out
there already you know the moon landings
happening in 1969.
okay so another fella says
and again uh it's uh if if they had a
pair of binoculars they wouldn't say
this but this says that
maybe it's a drone
you know maybe it's a drone that's up
there he wrote some other stuff in there
you know it it
can you tell the difference between a
tiny little drone you know maybe it's
one of those from ukraine that got lost
in ukraine war that got lost up there
well even then it's just
yeah but you're talking about you're
talking about um a monster football
field size object that is orbiting the
earth at 400 kilometers from here okay
so what are we saying we're saying that
um it's a huge drone that you can
calculate you know first first
verify that it's up there because if
it's not up there there's nothing to
calculate but once you see it up there
you say okay it's so big it's so distant
you know you can tell that true
telescope they have all this
uh measurement stuff there that you can
verify and you can say yeah this thing
is up there and then
all you have to do now is figure out how
you got up there okay do you have
something against the mooney stuff
because
well uh
putting everything let me tell you how
this is the pile kind of dilutes real
conspiracies though no problems against
it well no this is the issue like
separating the wheat from the chaff as
far as conspiracies go like some
conspiracies are warranted while others
are not yeah there's there's a couple
issues there one issue is that you know
intelligence agencies absolutely love
conspiracy theories that's why they
pissed so many in there and they have
people even supporting them because the
more theories that are out there the
less people will believe them they say
well hold it this guy believes in this
this guy believes in that i don't
believe in any of that
and so they go with the party line
and they go over the party line for
kennedy's assassination the
uh 911 and uh assange and uh ed snowden
and so you know when you put all this
together you say well hold it are they
just pitching more theories in there to
confuse people and so
so that people will finally get sick of
conspiracy theories yeah that is part of
the
strategy
but uh i i distinguish you know
kennedy's assassination which happened
in one second you know it's like it was
gone all right did you see it yeah yeah
yeah and you got the movie you know many
years later yeah that's one issue uh 9
11 happened in one day then the next day
the clean back this was like ongoing but
this one has been going on for years and
years and years you can go to cape
canaveral cape kennedy whatever down
there in florida
take your telescope and see if that
rocket is being thrown into space just
you know monitor it with your telescope
and see where it goes see if it just
falls you know on the other side of the
mountain or it continues going into
space if it goes into space then you say
hey we have the rockets to send them
into space in fact the russians i'm sure
are very much aware that the united
states can send rockets all the way to
russia through space through the arctic
and vice versa
and you know that's why they have all
these icbms and they're worried about
all that because if all that is not true
then you're saying oh that that never
happened that
that's not true that's fake well you
know i mean go to escaping avril and
find out if there are any rockets
whatsoever next time they have a launch
right if it goes into space and you can
verify in fact uh they film it but you
don't have to take their film for
granted take your own film you know make
your own film it seems like the
conspiracy theory that everyone's kind
of on now is the kovitz stuff around
like yeah
there's there's always conspiracy
theories about just about every subject
from
you know uh what is it but but climate
change but it's something that you said
as far as the cove thing also applies
here where when so many countries which
are supposedly enemies conspire on the
same conspiracy it gets kind of weird
like why would they yeah
that's that's my argument my primary
argument against uh kobe being a
conspiracy you can say that uh you know
the united states and europe got
together and they said let's do this to
confuse our people no problem but when
you have north korea cuba and uh you
know russia china and vietnam and all
these countries that are or to some
degree iran you know enemies of the
united states and they all agree to fool
their own people and they said let's all
agree
all these countries what is it 170 180
countries in the world you know and the
same thing applies to space travel why
would russia and the us both conspire to
say that we got people on the moon well
uh they they do have that where
i i discussed that uh because someone
said well
uh russia and the united states or
soviet union in those days right and the
united states got together and they
agreed
that they were going to fool the whole
world that they sent the probes into
space that uh gagarin went around the
earth first first man and tereshkova the
first woman like the first dog
and then there was this turtle that they
sent also to all the way to the moon
went around the moon and came back uh
turtle that's the first living entity
that went through the van allen belts
and so on okay and so we have all these
cases and then it turns out that it was
the americans that sent the um the first
humans to the moon and it turns out that
the americans never doubted never even
questioned whether you know gagarin
tereshkov i like how went into orbit and
the russians never questioned that
armstrong was the first man on the moon
yeah it's like you know and you would
say well is it that they agreed they
were such friends
uh these two countries uh that they
decided to
all the politicians on both sides they
these and uh astronauts and so on they
all decided that hey let's all be on the
same way uh you know paige let's all
fool the world
is that what happened
uh
i doubt it between enemies you know but
that's what people believe out there
that uh in secret all these people are
not enemies they're all friends and here
you have poutine you know he's killing
people in ukraine the americans uh are
feeding uh the ukrainian army with the
weapons to kill russians but all these
guys are drinking vodka and champagne
you know and getting together and having
a party while all these people are
killing themselves i don't think so
i think they're true genuine enemies but
if you believe otherwise i can't help
you you know go to ukraine and find out
or go to the
kremlin
anyways let's open the
uh i do have some questions here uh but
uh do we have any more questions there
from okay let me see if we can address
some of the questions that some people
made that outside the uh
topics we covered today and here's the
first one okay well it says bill what
does natural and unnatural mean
okay essential essentially he
goes
going into more detail there i'm saying
that uh natural is the opposite of
artificial artificial is what man
constructs or what a beaver constructs
okay that's
uh unnatural in the sense that it's
second hand the mother nature is using
some live entity to build something that
she hasn't built directly herself that
should be pollination natural or
unnatural yeah the the the um
you could say that well it depends on
what it's for if it's um if it's just to
feed themselves like they're producing
the food like when we grow uh
our own crops
uh there you're gonna say that it's more
like a hand in hand mother nature weird
there yeah i know it gets very
because it gets very um fuzzy you know
because on the one hand you have um
mother nature she made the seed the
original seed we modified it so the
modified seed is
an artificial seed
but the original seed was from mother
nature
so what i'm saying is the artificial
seed is
not natural we made it and mother nature
had no say or secondary saying that you
can say she she used us as a conduit as
a
mediator to make that seed and again
like i'm saying the beaver same thing
you know
she mother nature did not make the uh
you know the little house there would it
was the beaver who did it and mother
nature made the beaver so it's the
beaver who
uh serves as a mediator uh for that
artificial construction and so on you
know and you can analyze you know
bees uh
waxing um
what is it honey
you can go through everything uh is poop
uh from a cow is that artificial or is
that
well i would say that that's natural
because you know the cow has no option
the cow has to put he's uh
he's making a weird distinction national
artificially yeah all i'm saying is that
you know if there's a mediator or not in
the case of men it's a little more
clear-cut because you know we make a lot
of
artificial stuff especially machinery
and so on when you get into the natural
stuff like you know seeds and plants
well now you get into a little grayish
area and you gotta analyze it a little
more in detail but when you talk about
machines like making robots making
airplanes uh hopefully that's not
natural that's why i call when i talk
about life the definition of life i'm
saying that it's a natural object that
moves against gravity or the
path of least resistance
i say i have to say natural because you
know we make artificial robots they move
against
gravity they move against the path of
least resistance but mother nature did
not make the robot he made us not the
robot okay so that's
that's my take on it besides you know i
don't know what use you would have for
any artificial thing calling it uh life
for example pixels on a movie screen
yeah they move which is actually lights
lighting up that's all it really is but
let's assume the pixel itself moves no
problem
is that a
and you say well that's life because it
moves against gravity yeah you could say
that but what would be the purpose of
including artificial stuff under life i
mean what's the purpose of that is that
just to play devil's advocate or is it
that doesn't have a real purpose we're
trying to define life
uh in a natural way what what does
mother nature consider life and i'm
saying that the unit is the cell okay
it's the first entity that moves against
gravity primarily but you can say
against the path of least resistance
okay here we have another fellow and he
says the following
he says there is no energy and matter
other than that received from its
environment accordingly nikola tesla
weather doesn't move itself
uh yeah water is not life first of all
and then energy
if tesla said that energy is received
from the environment then he had no clue
obviously because energy is a concept
and we do not receive concept from the
environment
so
uh
tesla never had the wording right that's
why he was not a scientist he was just
an inventor that's all he was what's an
inventor a guy that does a thing a
million times until he gets it right
and tesla laughed at uh edison he worked
for edison at one time then he went to
work for westinghouse
and he left at
edison because he knew edison well he
said look if edison had to find
a needle in a handstand he would go
through every little straw until he
found the needle and he said when he
could have saved a lot of time just
doing some calculations and he was
probably right about that edison was not
a smart man he was in in that sense
you're not a technician i think um
edison was a good businessman but uh
tesla was a better uh
you know inventor in that sense he was a
tinkerer
but he what is a tinker what is that
they named trial and error that's all it
is he also went through every stick in
the haze yeah
you know finding the right way to get
amd and nintendo where i worked we did
the same thing it was all trial and
error and i can't say all because then
you have to test it okay well you see a
pattern and then you can skip some
triangles no and and you you okay so
because you made some measurements about
resistance you made measurements about
voltage about current and inductance and
all this other stuff then you already
have an idea it just helps you zero in
on a solution to the problem you have in
front of you but it's still trial and
error that doesn't mean you know what a
field is
or what light is or how what electricity
is it doesn't it doesn't follow that
because you work in the industry and you
make an assumption that you know
electricity is the flow of particles
meaning electrons from atom to atom that
that's actually what's happening there
okay in fact it's not according to our
site here okay
okay let me move on here we have a
couple more
uh fellow says
uh putting uh he's trying to define the
word time and he says time is change
uh no
time is not just change it's a little
more than change change is motion that's
with the synonym of motion change change
in motion mean the same thing because
you can't have change without motion
okay
the interval over which change occurs
okay that's a little better the only
problem is interval is a synonym of time
so you haven't said anything you haven't
defined the word time all you're saying
is that time is time or integral is
interval whichever we want to look at it
and something that repeats
uh predictably okay let's find out if
that's true uh here we have it
give me a second here
okay here's something that repeats
repeatably this is all that god made
okay god only made this ball okay tell
me what time it is
uh no not though
up down yeah i mean right now we don't
know couple o'clock yeah i have
something repeatable you know and and
the only way you're gonna be able to
determine time if you compare this
against another motion
you know what is time well uh let's give
a specific example one second which i
like to define okay what is one second
well one second originally not what it
is today but originally it was uh the
motion of the earth around the sun
and maybe not initially but you compare
it against the second hand on your watch
which moves one tick mark
and by the time that that hand moves
that one tick mark the earth moves 30
kilometers around
the sun and so you're comparing the
motion of the earth around the sun
against that little motion of your of
the second hand on your on your watch
and so you're comparing two motions
that's what time is and for that you
need memory you can't have time without
memory okay
to define it properly qualitatively we
have no use for quantitative time in
science that's mathematics only we have
no use for time
okay and uh let me get to the final
issue here i had a couple more i'm gonna
have to postpone them for time and fell
says light slows down in a medium
okay
and where did he get this well here we
have uh two prisms on the top uh upper
right okay in one case we have particles
in the other case we have waves okay
and so
the photo says look when you when you
have this white light uh impinging on
the prism what you get out is this uh
rainbow okay in both cases so the
question is can you simulate this with
particles are we saying that the
particles are slowing down
when they go through the prism
but when you measure outside the on the
right hand side of those two prisms you
find that light is still traveling at
300 000 kilometers per second almost you
know i mean
barring air right the medium of air so
are we saying that hold it the white
light
entering traveled at 300 000 kilometers
per second it slowed down
when it went through the prism bouncing
against whatever and then when it comes
out
why did it go back to 300 000 kilometers
per second what speeded it up
where did it get the energy to go fast
again
that's the question you have to answer
so you don't have that problem with a
rope model because rope mod is
consistent with the equation for light
which is little c 300 000 kilometers per
second equals frequency times wavelength
frequency and wavelength are inversely
proportional
okay so when frequency goes up
wavelength goes down and vice versa and
the only way you can simulate that
equation is with a rope
okay because you make the links
shorter and you have more links
frequency and you make the links longer
wavelength right and you have fewer
links meaning frequency so that's what
you have so there is no change in speed
of light light always travels at the
same speed through any medium between
any two atoms under the rope model all
you have is what you see there the
visible spectrum what what you have is
different link lengths and they
determine the different colors
okay that we see uh out there okay so
when you see colors what you're seeing
is different uh wave lengths meaning
link links and meaning that the more you
stretch the road the more the link is
stretched the fewer lengths you can
put in there okay and that's exactly
what that equation says c equals
frequency times wavelength that is the
equation of a rope okay so no light does
not travel at different speeds that's
only in mathematics why because they did
it through experiments and with
experiments you're not going to
figure out how this universe works
explain anything yeah you're not going
to be able to explain you have to
explain the experiment the result of the
experiment you can't just say oh i
measured okay you measured in what did
you measure well you measured
coming in 300 000 kilometers per second
coming out of the prism 300 000
kilometers per second
but obviously it broke it down in colors
which means that what that you have
different wavelengths
not that you have different speeds
okay and the only way you can do that is
with a rope rope simulates it perfectly
now maybe you have a better mechanism
maybe you have a chain
uh or something else i don't know i
can't imagine angels whatever you use
but you have to explain that why that's
the case can you row can do that can
simulate that
okay any other questions no no a lot of
comments okay folks we'll see you next
sunday i'm gonna be doing this uh every
sunday from now on uh partly due to
health issues i got a lot of work also
and so i'm gonna do it once a week from
now on sunday it sounds like a religious
thing yeah it's uh prayer time here's
mass 9 o'clock physical mass but
church mass okay we'll see you next
sunday folks bye